et même oui ça lui est d'accord et b
bonjour salut lille et 11 heures on est
dimanche et donc c'est le jour de
l'explication de la semaine puisque tous
les dimanches à 11h je te prends un truc
qui va permettre de bluffer tait sale
joue ta famille aussi si jamais tu as un
repas de famille dans une heure que
plutôt que de te lever tu regarde mes
vidéos sur youtube et aujourd'hui je
vais te donner quatre lits qui vont me
permettre d'avoir 80 % de réussite
lorsque tu joues au chifoumi le jeu
c'est fini c'est le jour où on a les
mains dans le dos et qu'on fait pierre
feuille ciseaux et qu'on peut donc ça
c'est fabrice à ces pierres ça a été
tellement drôle qui est un pote qui
s'appelle pierre qui passe derrière et
ça évidemment ce sont des nantais doit
on la bonne noval mme évidemment ça ce
sont les six donc tu connais le jeu
quand elle avec quelqu'un chacun fait
son signe et on comparer on voit
qu'elles signent gagné donc la feuille
gagnent la pierre la pierre garrigues
des ciseaux les ciseaux coupe la feuille
c'est un cercle complètement équilibré
puisque chaque figure gagne sur une
autre et on pas une autre et moi j'ai
quatre astuces pour avoir 80% de
réussite et je te la donne bien sûr je
te les donne c'est le bide du dimanche
des fois j'étais juste fou quand
j'avance ma première astuce à se base
sur un principe sicot logique assez
simple en france souvent on joue à
feuilles pierre cizeau ou puis on a
rajouté le puits ce qui n'a pas de sens
puisque l'isf et bâle par une seule
figure la feuille et il en va de les
ciseaux et la pierre mais dans le frais
chiffres n'y est pas ça et donc vous
allez le rappeler à votre adversaire
vous dites simplement et on est un
chiffon mis du côté cette pierre feuille
ciseaux par contre y'a pas de puyoô
qu'est le fils de lui rappeler qu'il
n'ya pas depuis c'est une espèce de
suggestions pour qu'ils prennent la
pierre parce que comme le fuit et d'une
figure très puissante ok puisqu'elle
gagne sur deux il a cherché dans sa tête
le plus fort juste après le puits
d'après lui et comme ce jeu se base sur
des images très simple il va choisir la
pierre qu'un signe de force alors qu'en
fait statistiquement ils ont les mêmes
chances de gagner les autres donc comme
il ya de fortes chances en ayant dit
cette phrase juste avant ils prennent la
pierre
mais coupe au premier coup vous allez
prendre la feuille essayer le vraiment
de la manière suivante et vous allez
voir vous allez quasiment
systématiquement gagné au premier coup a
reçu des bouteilles
enfin je veux dire rapidement j'essaie
d'arrêter de vous tutoyer dans les
vidéos fait ce que parce que ça n'a pas
de sens et je mélange le voulait le tuer
et je viens de me rendre compte que
j'avais encore mélangez les deux je
continue quand même excusez moi si je
fais des trucs bizarres des fois quand
je parle je vous disais j'ai jamais
partagé cette première secousse avec
quelqu'un et elle me fait gagner
quasiment systématiquement le premier
coup donc faites le vous allez voir
c'est assez fun et ça va vous faire rire
la deuxième astuces elle est simplement
de l'ordre statistiques mais elle est
vérifiée un joueur fait rarement trois
fois la même figure d'affilée ça c'est
quelque chose que vous pouvez prendre en
compte si quelqu'un fait une fois ci aux
deux fois ciseaux il va pas faire trois
aux ciseaux ou alors c'est extrêmement
rare c'est quelque chose que vous devez
garder à l'esprit en permanence pour
switcher et les deux autres astuces
elle me viennent d'une université
chinoise l'université de ces gens que je
ne sais pas si je prononce bien j'ai
page pas l'accent chinois ça s'appelle
c'est chiant bien et il ya deux ans ils
ont réuni 360 étudiants et durant deux
heures ils leur ont fait des matches
comme ça de chifoumi et ils ont observé
ce qui se passait en termes de résultats
pour l'associer à un processus
psychologique vérifier il en est
ressorti deux conclusions qui permettent
de gagner deux fois sur trois deux fois
sur trois c'est 66 % de chance c'est
énorme
déjà ça se base sur le fait que dans
notre tête on dit toujours pierre
feuille ciseaux on joue dans cet ordre
là d'ailleurs conduit chifoumi c'est
pierre feuille ciseaux donc je pars
chinois en fait et tout est basé sur ce
qui vient de se passer du point de vue
de votre adversaire pour essayer
d'anticiper son prochain il ya deux
choses à savoir si vous faites un coût
et que l'adversaire gagne le joueur d'en
face viens juste de gagner
vous n'êtes de faire pierre par exemple
tout à fait funk donc il a gagné
beaucoup d'après vous devez jouer ce qui
vous aurait fait gagner ce coup là quand
un joueur gagne il a tendance à refaire
le même symbole au coup d'après donc
s'il gagne avec pierre au coup d'après
il ya 2
chance sur trois pour qu'il joue pierre
de nouveau donc si vous venez de perdre
contre pied avec les ciseaux ou d'après
vous faites la feuille il ya de chance
sur trois pour qu'il fasse la pierre et
que vous gagnez ce coup là que si votre
adversaire père alors il la tendance à
changer de signes pour le signe après
dans la routine pierre faye ciseaux donc
s'il joue pierre et qui perd contre vous
au coude après il va faire feuilles du
moins il ya deux chances sur trois pour
qu'il fasse feuilles au coup d'après
vous vous en rappelez plus facilement de
votre point de vue si vous perdez vous
jouez le figure d'avant dans la routine
pierre feuille ciseaux si vous perdez
avec feuilles vous faites pierre au coup
d'après et si vous gagnez beaucoup
d'après vous fait le symbole suivant
donc si vous gagnez avec le ciseau par
exemple vous faites pierre au coup
d'après c'est très simple ça vous donne
deux chances sur trois de gagner à
chaque fois c'est à dire que si vous
jouez un match en dix coups avec
quelqu'un vous appliquez ma première
astuce pour le premier coup ensuite vous
appliquez ces deux astuces là en cas de
gain ou de perte à chaque fois
systématiquement garder quand même en
tête
ma deuxième astuces qui était qu'un
joueur ne joue jamais trois fois le même
symbole d'affilée et vous êtes sûr candy
coup vous gagnerez votre parti de
chifoumi et là tu peux te faire plaisir
au niveau des paris on vous voyez par
exemple qui va ranger l'appartement le
coup tu te propose une partie de
chifoumi ont du coup pour déterminer ça
c'est pas très compliqué car des biens
c4 astuces antennes
amusez-vous bluffé tout le monde gagne
et laïque et cette page mais tu es un
pouce en l'air commenté abonnez vous me
suivez le mental vlog à demain à 17
heures ciao